Ernie Russ Bielski is a history teacher
at Stoneman Douglas high is being hailed
a hero today he directed dozens of
students to safety during last week's
shooting Ross Pierre ski also known as
mr. R was grazed by a bullet in a
third-floor confrontation with the
gunman he has been attending funerals
and vigils for some of his students over
the weekend while others demand action
in response to these killings
Ernie Rose BR ski is with us from
parkland Florida thank you very much mr.
Ross Pierre ski for joining us we know
this is painful and difficult and it
will continue this week but you were
being hailed a hero you save students at
your own peril there reports that you
were grazed on the cheek by a bullet
that you actually saw Nicholas Cruz
reloading his gun what did you see and
what did you do when you realize that
this was not a drill well when I saw it
was not a drill the first thing I was
yelling at my kids was to get to cover
when I was in the middle of the hallway
at the time and I saw him point these
gun at one of my former students I saw
him go down and then I grabbed all my
kids I couldn't push them into our doors
have a little alcove in front of them
and I grabbed my kids and push them in
there because it was the only cover I
could find and four or five shots later
it stopped so that's when I looked at
poke my head around saw he was either
fidgeting with a gun reloading or
something told my kids to run and then
we left as fast as we could you must be
very proud of your kids today mr. Ross
Pierre ski because many people are
saying this shooting feels different
these students are speaking out and they
are speaking out in ways that we have
not heard before the kids are the
students that summon Douglas have been
terrific not just the kids that you've
had a chance to hear speak but I
personally witnessed one of my kids
holding the door his name is Peter Wang
hold the door pushing kids through the
door while bullets are coming at him I
don't know when you had many adults who
could have done that let alone a 14 year
old boy and then the response from our
students who are still around and still
able to talk they're taking that
opportunity they're empowered and
they're angry Ernie the president says
he's going to have a listening
or in the wake of this what would you
want to tell him about your students and
what you've experienced I'd want to say
to the president that we have great kids
we have more great kids we have 14 great
kids who needed protection that we
couldn't give them I lost three kids in
my class I couldn't help them I
shouldn't have had to and it's one of
those things that as a lifelong gun
owner and a hunter I'm not saying we
should stop the Second Amendment I'm not
saying we should take guns away from
people I'm saying there's no point to
somebody having an in a ar-15 and if
somebody wants to argue with me on that
that's cool if you want an ar-15 we'll
go to the range I get to shoot at you I
get to graze you with a bullet I get to
catch you with some fragments like I did
and then after that if you still want to
buy said weapon cool then I'm gonna talk
to have you talk to a psychologist
because that guns not designed to do
anything besides kill people the round
itself is unstable and tumbles
that's not normal that's an contra
version of the Geneva Convention or at
least a way around it and people need to
know that and people need to realize
especially the president because he has
the most power in the free world in the
world and we need to do something to
save these kids and to protect our
children not just my kids but I have a
17 month old son at home I don't want to
have to send him to school and have him
face this stuff I'm a 36 year old man
and I'm having trouble dealing with it I
could only imagine what these kids are
dealing with we all are Ernie Russ
Pierce Key thank you for what you do as
a teacher and leading so many students
and for joining us this morning we
appreciate it thank you my pleasure
we're thinking of you